えっと まあどういうわけかわかりませんだけど
なんかこういう日にちに合わせたテーマになってまして
まあお掃除する時期になりましたからね
まあこのテーマについては
まあこの前もどこかで覚えていないんですけど
まあ話したことはありますから
今日はまあ全部リピートになりますので
どうも面白くないんだったらね
音を立てないで いびきをかかないでご休みになってください
いびきは禁止です で あの
まあ一応 まあテーマはそれですから
説明する必要な なんかちょっと私はリプレースしなかったんです
試せなかったんで ちょっとトラブルがあるみたい
はい まずは汚れを確認するということで
あの この心の汚れを落とすってこと
これすごい大変なテーマなんですね
仏教ではね 仏教の場合はまあそれがテーマなんです
別にいろいろ仕事あるわけじゃなくて
まあ心はどうやって綺麗にするのかいっていうことが仏教のテーマなんですね
ですから なかなかこれはどうやって喋る
何を喋ればいいかとさっぱりわからなくなっていたんです
で まあ一部一部その中でね
明確に説明するのはできますけど
全体的に仏教のすべてを説明してくださいと言っちゃうとね
早く死んでくださいという人がないんです
もうできるわけないんです
だから  このあの 私たちの仏教はね
上座部仏教とテーラワーダ仏教とも言いますけど
あの まあテーラワーダ仏教の場合は
なんでテーラワーダってテーラワーダでいうのかとかね
テーラワーダの基本的な教えはね
まあ他の宗派とはね 違って
基本的な教えは何なのかとね
しっかりと 定めたテキストがございまして
これはすべての経典に対する中心になる注釈書なんですね
浄道論と言うんですね
清浄道論 この清浄道論というのは
インドから来たブッダ教説中お坊さんが書いた本ですけど
スリランカの大お坊さんたちが彼に宿題というか
テーマを挙げたんですね
このテーマ この三行の下なんですね
四行の四行の下をテーマとして挙げて
それに注釈しなさいと
それからその作品の道経を見て
他の注釈書をパーリ語に訳することができ
まあ認めるかないかということですね
いわゆる注釈書というのは
スリランカで大量にものすごい量がありまして
それは誰にもアクセスはできなかったですね
だから この南インドの仏教徒らが
なんとかそれはパーリ語にしてね
誰にも読めるものにしなくちゃいけないというね
気持ちがありましたけど
まず資格を調べたんですね
できるかと それで 彼に挙げた宿題
いわゆる研究テーマは
このサンユッタニカーヤに出てくる
アントジャータバヒジャータ
まあ生命は精神的にもいろんなもつれて
あれやこれやとか束縛に結ばれてあって
バヒジャータ世界社会大会に対してもね
外の世界に対しても あらゆる束縛で結ばれていて
ジャタージャティタパジャ
結び 結び 結び 結び 結び
結びばっかしで どうにもならんとか
生命は 淡々 ゴータマブッダも
このポイントは釈尊に聞きます
こう イマンウィジャタエージャタン
誰がこの結び 結び 結びの無数の結びをね
ウィジャタエーか 届いてほどいて自由にするのかいという質問がお釈迦様に出されたんですね
お釈迦様は四行で答えたんですね
シーレーパティッタナローサパンニョーチッチャンチッタンパンニャンチャバーヤンアーターピニパコビクコイマンヴィジャタソイマンヴィジャタエジャタンという偈な
んですね
まあ道徳を守って 心と智慧を育てて
それからしっかりと精進する人が精進する比丘がこの結びをほどいて見せますという
で まあその四行にした注釈書がテーラワーダ仏教の基本的なテキストになっていて
でっかい本なんです それから皆様も覚えている
この諸仏の仏教は何かというところでね
サッブパーパッサカラなんていう偈がございましてね
悪をやるないことで クサラスッパサンパダ善には達するもので
サチッタパリヨーダパナン
自分の心を清らかにすることで
これが仏です ブッダの教えであると
だからそこで三番目に出てくるのは
自分の心を清らかにする
だからブッダの教えといえば
心を清らかにすることに決まっているんです
別な考え もう一つ意見がありますよとかないんです
だから別な学派で別な意見がありますよとか
そんなことは言えません
ないんです ただ単に ブッダの教えは心を清らかにすること
もし他の人が他のことを言っているならば
それは明らかに仏教ではなくなっちゃうんですね
だから変なことをね あっちこっちからね
まあ迷信やらね 人の宗教のしきたり盗んで仏教に持ってくると
仏教の保守派が追い出すんです
出て行け 出て行きなさいと
呪文やら祈祷やら護摩供養やらね
持ってくると この邪教どもが出て行ってくださいと
どこかでやってくださいという感じで追い出すんです
だから心を清らかにすることが
まあブッダの道なんですね
そうなってくると 護摩供養をやっている人々も
やっぱり護摩供養で心が清らかになるんだとという話に持ってくるんですね
やっぱりそれ言わなかったら
この仏教のお世話になれないんですね
仏教という傘の下にいないと
あんまり商売繁盛しないんです
だからとにかくどんな変なことをやっても
我は仏教であるということを言わなくちゃいけなくなっているんですね
自分の身の安全のために
だから護摩供養の人々に聞いても
やっぱりそれで心の汚れがなくなりますと
だからあの木の板で 板にいろいろ自分の悩み
を書いて あのー 燃やしてもらいます
大変な素晴らしいことですけどね
まあ本当はそれじゃないんですよ
本当は自分の体に全部自分の悩みやら煩悩やらね
体中墨で書いて 自分で火に飛び込まない限りはね
これは一向に清らかにならないと思いますけど
まあかわいそうにね まあ植物
木の板切れを燃やしてね
まあ板切れを燃やしてね
焼き芋でも焼くならばね
これは反対はできませんけどね
あれにも使わないんですね
ただ単に燃やすだけでね
もったいないんですね
まあ今度お寺で護摩供やってくると
皆様あの芋でも持ってきてください
芋とか餅とかね お坊さんがついでにこれも焼いてくださいと
その方がいいと思いますけどね
何か役に立ちますからね
まあまあ そういうことで
あのいろいろ仏教も迷信だらけで
まあ非科学的で もうもうもうもう話にならないぐらいもう世界でなってますけど
やっぱりどちらでも まあこれやれば心が清らかになるんだという立場だけは
まあもう変えないんですね
で なぜかというと やっぱりブッダの教えは心清らかにするということになってるんだからね
そちらは議論成り立ちません
だからみんな頭がいいんだからね
心を清らかにした人が教えた方法は置いといて
我々心汚い連中が自分たちで考えてやりましょうという
いわゆる勉強っていうのは
有名な先生に教授に勉強勉強してもらうんじゃないんだよと
どっかのアホでアホのグループを集めて
アホのクラブを作って
そこで研究をやるというやり方なんですね
仏教の宗派はそんなもんなんです
だからあのテーラワーダ仏教は
まあそれはちょっとおかしいんじゃないかなと
心清らかにしたいと思うならば
心清らかにした人のやり方を聞かなくちゃあかんでしょうにと
どうしようもないろくでもない人にどうすればいいんでしょうかと聞くのはね
ちょっとおかしいんじゃないかっていう立場を取ってるんですね
まあそういうことで テーラワーダ仏教では
他の宗派の教えは全く参考にしないで
あの釈迦さんの言葉だけ参考にして説明していきます
まあわかるところもあるし
わからないところもあるし
まあどうせわかるところであって
どうせあんまりそんなに理解したいというね
気もないんだからね まあわかるところであっても理解しないということもあるし
いろいろですけど まあ一応頑張ってみましょう
で まずはね 心を清らかにする前に
あの なんで清らかにしなくちゃあかんですかね
それは大きな問題で それってそんなに必須ですかね
心を清らかにするっていうことは
やっぱりそれで心は本当に汚れているんですかと
そこから始めなくてはいけないんですね
そこでこの まあなんとなく汚れているんだというね
話は世の中で一般的にはあります
で 他の宗教でも 人間というのは心は汚くて罪人だというね
話があります それっていうのはなんとなく言ってるんだって
あの それはあの 生きることは大変でしょ
あの昔からも今も 生きることっていうのはもう大変な作業なんです
朝から晩まで苦労しないと生きていられないんですよ
1日 2食しかね 昔の人も食べなかったんだけど
この 2食食べる時は時間というのはまあまあ大体 30分ぐらいで終わりますよ
この 30分もかからないご飯を食べるために
1 日中仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
だからその状況はそんなに変わってないんですね
経済大国だといっても
皆様方もものすごい 1 日中仕事をしているんです
それで昔の人よりすごい贅沢しているんですよと言ったっても
そんな大した贅沢してないんです
し もうローンで生活しているんだからね
昔の人々よりもたちが悪いんです
昔の人々はローンっていうのはね
もう人間失格やと普通に思っていたんです
で そういうことだから
私たちに至っては 生きることはそんなに楽な作業じゃないんですよ
大変なことなんです それで人間というのは真面目に考えたんです
なんでこんなに大変ですかと
なんでね 森に入ったらね
もう鹿とかイノシシとかね
のこのこと自分勝手に前に出てこないんですかね
はい どうぞ私を撃って食べてくださいとかね
魚を焼いて焼いて食べたいんだけど
川に入ったらみんな逃げちゃうんですね
失礼なところでしょうにね
一応魚食べたいと川に入ったら
魚がなんで勝手に出てきてね
もう手を出したら 手に何で飛んでこないんですかね
手を出したところ 手の中に美味しそうな魚が入ってくれれば
人生って楽でしょ それで取って焼いて食べればいいしね
魚も本当に人間に対してえらい失礼ですね
逃げますから だから魚釣るのも大変な作業なんです
そういうことだから まあ人間がね
偉いなのに 現実はちょっと人間馬鹿にしているんですね
それにはやっぱり腹が立ちますよ
なんでイノシシが逃げるのかいと
なんで魚が逃げるのかいと
逃げてあかんでしょうにとか思っていてね
まあそれに何か理由を考えたんですね
だから素晴らしいことを身思い立ったんですね
人間がこの なんか間違ったことやったんじゃないんですかと
最初は だからそこは原罪といってね
まああの 人間は最初からなんか罪を犯しているんだと
それがずっと代々 もうつなげていくんだと続けていくんだと
だからですよ 病気になるのもね
もう釣り竿を投げたら魚が逃げて逃げるのが
だから水に網をかけたら
普通だったら魚たちが
ほら みんなのものよ あの人は網をかけたんだから
じゃあ行って入ってくださいと
魚たちはそう言わないんですね
逃げるというんですね
失礼なこと だから  それが人間が何かもう罪を犯したからということになっているんです
年取りの病気になることも
全てで苦しみがね ですから
その物語の場合も やっぱり何か人間の心はね
というか なんかおかしいということだけは考えているんです
それは仏教は認めませんね
これちょっと態度でかいんですね
あの話は 人間がね すべての生命の中の神様で
もう人間を褒め称えて生活しなくちゃいけないだろうと
あなた方はという態度なんですね
しかし 王様がちょっと悪いことをしたんだから
家来たる動物たちに舐められているんだという話ですから
ちょっと態度でかいんですが
まあそういうふうな 面白くて素晴らしい話ね
神にしか理解できない話は仏教ではないんです
仏教にあるのはすごい
そんなにレベルが高くないんだけど
人間に理解できる話なんです
だからごく普通なね あのエイリアンでもね
来てコソコソと教えてくるならばいいんだけどね
そういう話もなんともなく
UFO も見えない  UFO からいろんな情報も入らない
チャネリングもできない
日本にいますよ 宇宙のいろんな果てから
いろんな星からチャネリングするんですね
して すごい情報知ってるんだとかね
何知ってるかやっぱりわからないんだけど
自分がチャネリングしていると言うんですね
まあまあ そういうふうな
このすごい普通と違った能力ではなくてね
そんなもの何もない ごく一般の人々の立場から仏教は語られています
ですから 心を清らかにするぞと言ったら
あれ またなんで？という質問が出てくるんですね
と なんでじゃなくて 心汚れているでしょうにと
あ 本当？という質問が出てくる
汚れている そうよ 汚れている
では 汚れというのはこれこれやと教えてあげましょうということで
汚れを教えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから まず汚れはあることを教えてあげます
だから 一般人の知識でそんなのは汚れじゃないよという気持ちだったら
もうしょうがない もう話は終わり
あるいはやっぱりそれが汚れですねという気持ちになったら
もう続けて話を聞かなくちゃいかないんです
どちらかにいてください
話は面白くなくて 逃げたいんだったら
いいえ そんなのは心の汚れじゃないと言って逃げたってもいいんです
そうすると立場が守れます
えーと  それから心の汚れのリスト
一部のリストですね いろいろありますけど
出します なんで心を清らかにしなくちゃいけないかっていうとこはね
まあまあいろいろあるんですね
心が汚れているんだから
生きることは苦しいんですね
それで我々知ってる苦しみっていうのは
あの  そんなに大げさなことでもないんですね
仮に言ったら ちょうどいいところでイノシシがいてほしい
それだけなんです 釣り竿をね
川に投げたらすぐパクッと食ってほしいんですね
あの餌を あれ えらい楽しいでしょ
日本ではかなり品格のある趣味でもあるでしょ
釣りは まあテレビ テレビでもすごい時間をかけて
ものすごい時間をかけて
この番組まで流してますよ
だから殺して楽しむんだというね
文化ですからね 殺すことは楽しいんだと
そんな魚釣って魚殺して
そんなにも楽しいんだったら
なんで互いに殺し合いやらないんですかね
もっと楽しいでしょうね
それが なんで魚狙うんですかね
魚には攻撃もできないし
だからこれからいいんですよ
にね 私はこの釣りの釣りが趣味という人々が
包丁とかね 野球バットとか持ってね
あっちこっち街角で構えていて
人を殺してみると やったー
一丁上がりだとかね もし相手が老人だったら
あんまりいいものじゃないとかね
今日は出来が悪いんだと
歳 歳の人を人ぐらい倒すことできたら
今日は収穫はいいんだぞとかね
喜べばいいんですけどね
まあとにかく同じ気持ちでしょうね
魚殺して喜ぶっていうことも
まあ人間が考える この人間が生きる幸福っていうのは
そんなに大げさなことではなくて
畑 田んぼがね 豊作になることやら
で 大学卒業すると何のこともなくいい仕事をね
自分のやりたい仕事を見つけることやら
そこで仕事の能力もね
何のことなく淡々と身につくことやらね
で それから仕事もあまり難しくなくて
給料だけは場が高いとかね
期待しているのはそんな程度のことやと思いますよ
1ヶ月間仕事をすると 2週間ぐらい休みくれるとかね
あるいは二 三時間仕事をすればいいやとかね
給料は過ぎ過ぎ あの万円とかね
まあそれからあの 何て言ったっけ
まあボーナスもある あるとかね
年に一回外国旅行するためにもお金が出るとかね
まあそういうふうなことを言わない仕事があればね
まあありがたいなと思っちゃいますね
まあそこをまとめてちょっと大げさに言いましたけど
まあまとめてみればね
ほんのに本当にちっぽけな希望はしか持ってないんで
そんなに大胆な達することできそうもない希望を我々は持ってないんです
それほど苦しくない仕事があればいいやとかね
仕事からの収入でね まあなんとか人生間に合っているんだと
まあちょこちょこ貯金もできるんだと
まあ少々節約すればね
欲しい品物を 贅沢品もなかなか
まあ一応買えるます 買えますよという程度の幸せを我々は目指しているんです
あの世界制覇しようとかは思ってないんです
それでシンプルな目的なんですが
いわゆる当たり前の希望なんですけどね
いい仕事欲しいなっていうのは当たり前の希望でしょうしね
別に悪いことじゃないでしょうね
この当たり前の希望であっても
なかなかうまくいかないという
健康でいたいっていうことは
もう普通 普通な常識的な希望なんですけど
なかなかそれが叶わないという問題があるんですね
そこが大きな問題なんですよ
まあ人間がね まあ大胆なことを希望するならばね
叶わないのはいいんだけど
すごい大胆なことをね
あのプライベートジャンボ機欲しいやとかね
豪華客船何船っていうんですか？豪華船
船が欲しいとかね そのようなけたちが希望があったら
あのね そんなのは叶うわけないでしょうとは言えますよ
しかし 人がね 自分の息子が今就職活動していますけど
あいつには何かいい仕事を見つかってほしいなというお母さんの希望は何が悪いんですかね
人間というのは叶って当たり前の希望ですよ
持っているのは では毎日旅行したいと思ってないでしょ？まあ 1年に 1回
2回ぐらい どこかで面白いところに行って
2日  3日間ぐらい遊んで帰りたいというね
まあごく普通 常識的で当たり前で
叶った方がいい希望ばっかりなんです
それさえも叶わないんですね
ですから そこら辺の理由がありまして
で その理由が この私達の生き方はすべて心が決めるんです
心が支配者なんです 私はどうなるのかいということを
私の心が勝手に決めるんです
心が勝手に決めたら まあどうにもならないんですね
だから この小さな常識的な
どうったことない 誰でも満たしてほしいと思う基本的な希望
標準的な希望でしょ 我々持っているのは
誰も標準超えた希望は持ってないんです
この標準的な希望は作ったのが心です
作ってからそれは決して叶うようにしてあげませんと
いうあべこべなことも心がやっているんです
だから自分が希望を作って
自分がその希望が叶わないように
失望になるようにもうからくりをして
生きることを苦しみということにしてしちゃうんです
このからくり 全部心が勝手にやっているんです
人に聞かないんです 他人が言うと腹立たしいんです
放っておきなさいと だから皆さんも人に言ってみてくださいね
もうあなた方 あなた方のね
この態度ではね 勉強できませんよと
その態度ではいい仕事を見つかりませんよと言ってみてください
怒られますよ だから例えば有名な会社ばっかり狙ってますけど
あなたはね 今有名な会社ではもう人を雇って雇いませんよと
しかし この中流というか
この普通のね 中小企業
中小企業がいっぱいありまして
もう仕事もありまして
人がいないんだよと だからそちらに入ったらストレスもなく腕も上がるし
ストレスもなく 何人かのおじさんと一緒に仕事もできるし
仕事も楽しいし 自分も職人さんになるし
だからそこを探せばって言ったら怒られますよ
若者に言ってみてください
何言うのかいと 俺は大企業者企業に入りたいんだよと
だからそういう風にも我々の心が希望を作って
この希望が叶わない方向へ働いてくれます
これが心ということなんです
なんか信じられない矛盾というかね
仏教は人間の生命の場合は
それって大きな問題ですよ
それ 個人個人の心の問題なんですね
まあ例えばね もう音楽家とかね
すごい体力も必要な集中力も必要な仕事でしょ
それだったら体力 集中力を育てて
心を穏やかにした方が新しい音楽の
作ることできるでしょ
その代わりにその人は何するのかというと
一日中ふさぎで混乱ばっかし
頭の中でもう酒やら飲みたい放題飲んで
クタクタ脳細胞を壊す
それから見栄を張ったり
我を張ったり 人と喧嘩したりとか
もうガタガタな性格を作る
それから一人で では何か音楽を作りましょうと
作れるわけないでしょう
全く しかし 音楽の能力もあるし
音楽家としても成功もしたいし
だからといって だからこの性格しますよと
音楽能力をすべて破壊する生き方をするんです
みんなそういうことなんですよ
なんでそうなるのかと
だから人にアドバイスすることも気をつけた方がいいんです
人にアドバイスすることほど悪いこと
だから言ったら怒られます
だったら聞かない方がいいでしょ
私に電話かけてどうすればいい？どうすればいい？と言うんだけど
何か私はこの電話会社にこれから頼みます
電話を通して何か爆弾でも送れる方法ないのかと
私は聞くなよとはっきり言うんです
なんで私に聞くんですかと
あんた困ってる ことわかってますけど
でもあんたやりたくないでしょうにと
自分喜んでそういうことをしたでしょうにと
今更どうするべきかと聞いたっても
あなた聞かないでしょうにと
いえいえ ちゃんと聞きますと言ったら
わしはまあ この前 この前
何年前  １年前  ７年前 あなた私はこういうことを言ったでしょうにと
まだ逆らったでしょ 今も同じことしか言うことないんだと
それ言ったら 今日 今日
今あんた逆らうでしょうにと
だったら電話さえかける必要ないでしょうに
あれは道連れ機能なんですね
自分が自壊を破壊の道に行くんだけど
もう一人にアドバイスを受けて
その人を道連れにして
その人も不幸のどん底に落としたいんです
だから人のアドバイスは聞くんです
人のアドバイス聞いても
あの人はやらないでしょ
例えば 自殺願望の人がカウンセラー何人かに聞くんです
真面目に聞くんで だからすーっと
はいはい わかりました
はい わかりました よく助かりました
よく理解しましたと言って
じゃあ頑張ってみます
今日から それでカウンセラー騙されます
すごく喜ぶ やっと自分の人生よかったと
一人の人間助かること
助けてあげることはできたぞとかね
調子に乗るんです そこで他のカウンセラーのところに行くんです
行ってあいつは必ず自殺するんです
それ聞いた途端 あのカウンセラーの人々は
うちに来たんだけどね
やっぱり私はもうしっかりした方がよかったとかね
もっと丁寧にアドバイスした方がよかったとかね
あるいは自分の方から電話かけて
電話かけて 状況どうですかと調べた方がよかった
失敗してしまったと言って
その人も悩み 苦しむのどん底に陥るんです
カウンセリング仕事をする自信も失ってしまうんです
だから人間っていうのはそういう存在なんです
自分で不幸に幸福になりたいと決めてから
不幸になる道を選んで
勝手に不幸になればいいのに
他の人々も道連れにするんです
しかし 微塵も自分の道が間違っていると思わないんです
自分が正しいと だからまあ
世界で人に言ってはいけないことなんですね
君 それちょっとおかしいんじゃない？という一言葉は
言ってはいけませんよ
私の真似だけは絶対しないでください
まあ殺されます いつでも君ってすごいとかね
ああ これすごいなとかね
あ びっくりしましたと
あなたすごい世の中ですごい珍しいことを考えていますねとかね
とにかく褒めまくらなくちゃいけないんです
無事生活したければ 人が今日は酒飲めないと言ったら
それを褒めてあげる 今日はむちゃくちゃ酒飲むそうで言ったら
それまた褒めてあげる
素晴らしいですね その自由な思考はね
やっぱり羽伸ばして 人間っていうのはね
あなたすごい模範ですよと
それで酒飲んで もうもう立てる立てない状態になったところで
俺が家に帰ると どうやって帰ります？電車で
素晴らしいですね そんなに体力があって
ここまで酒飲んでも家に帰れたいっていうことはね
それだと褒めなくちゃいかないんです
ここで電車に乗って 電車の中でゲロ吐いちゃったら
それまた褒めなくちゃいけないんです
もし家にもう帰ることできなくて
途中で倒れちゃって 朝までそのままゴロゴロと寝ていたならば
朝起きたらもうみんなで褒めなくちゃいけないんですね
やっぱりすごいと 人間でのそういう性格なんですよ
人間の心はね 直すのは嫌なんです
じゃあ直すのは嫌だったら
幸福な道 生き方知っていますか？というと
絶対やってないんです
それであなた不幸になりたいのかと聞いたら
何聞くのかいと 不幸になりたいのは当たり前でしょうとまた反論するんです
はい そういう精神状態だから
すべての人間がね これは何とかしなくちゃいけない
しかし どこから手を出そうかと
手を出す方法さえないんです
だからお釈迦様は悟りに達して
最初のお釈迦様の感想は絶対教えてやらないと
こんなのは一人教えるんじゃないんだと
それが素直に常識の当たり前の感想なんです
言っても理解しないだろうと
攻撃するだろうと 反論するだろうと
それで攻撃したり反論したりすると
なおさらその人々が困るでしょうにと
ブッダは困りません 一人ですからね
人間が今も困っているところにお釈迦様が正しい生き方を教えちゃうと
これに向かって攻撃するんだから
新しい問題が現れるんですね
だからやめたっていうことにしたんです
お釈迦様は で あの まあそれでも仏教を教えて教えましたけど
やっぱりいまだに大変ですよ
理解してくれないんです
攻撃するんです 仏教を壊そうと
必死なんです みんな もう何とかして壊せないんだったら湾曲でもしようと
私の人生でもね そのままブッダの教えは素晴らしいと
もうもうやっぱり実践しましょうという人
見つかったことないんです
なんとか湾曲しようと思っちゃうんです
だから私ももう 65 年間も生きてきましたから
ずっと付き合いは仏教の人々でしょ
見つかってないんですが
もしかすると一人二人ぐらいいるかいたかもしれませんだけど
どう考えても なんとかちょっとだけでも自分の気持ちをに変えたいんですね
すごい世界なんです  はい
そういうことで やっぱり心は清らかにしない限りはもう話にならない
今までの説明はそのためなんです
生きるということは 心という独裁者の意のままなんです
心以外別に何もないんです
肉体は心を使っている道具だけで
だから心という独裁者がいて
皇帝がいて 誰の話も聞きません
自分勝手に生きている
このこいつはイカれてるんです
まず この独裁者である命が
だからそれをなんとか治すしか話にならないんですね
そういうわけで 心を清らかにすることっていうのは
もう絶対的な条件で それしかやることないんです
私たちに 商売繁盛にそんなにしがみついて
死に物狂いで頑張らなくてもいいんです
心を清らかにすれば 商売繁盛するんです
汚い心が商売をダメになる結論を出すんです
だから いろいろね 健康になりたい
商売繁盛 いろんな希望があるでしょうに
どんな希望でも 心さえ清らかだったら
もう何事も淡々淡々と当たり前でうまくいくんです
だから あれやこれや耐えるんじゃなくて
自分が自分の心を清らかにしちゃえば話は終わりますということなんですね
はい そこから次に飛びます
心の汚れって何なのかと
一 アビッジャー ヴィサマローボー
チッタッサ ウパッキーです
それはあの 貪欲ですね
異常欲は心の汚れです
あのアビッジャーという仏教専門用語がございまして
それがお釈迦様が定義するんです
ヴィサマローボーと ヴィサマローボーっていうのは常識じゃない
尋常でない欲なんですね
だからアビッジャーっていうのは
私はずっと異常欲 異常欲と訳してきたんです
異常欲と訳したのは まあお釈迦様の言葉では
アビッジャーっていうのは異常欲だと教えているんだからなんです
普通は貪欲と訳しますけどね
まあ貪欲でもよろしいし
異常欲 ちょっと尋常じゃないんです
ちょっと常識が外れているんです
まあ例えば お腹が空いたらご飯食べたいという欲が出てきますよ
これは常識でしょうね
まあせっかく食べるんだからおいしいものを食っちゃおうと思うでしょ
それを異常？異常じゃないんです
ご飯が食べたいなという欲も異常じゃないし
やっぱりせっかく食べるんだからね
まあ美味しいものを食べましょうよと
楽しく食べましょうよというところまでは大丈夫です
これがちょっと常識の範囲を超えるんですね
異常欲になるんです その時は
だからこの常識範囲はどこまでかというと
一般論はないんです だから一人一人がそれ決めなくちゃいけないんです
私の経済能力から見れば
この程度は常識で これ以上はやっぱり異常やと
例えば  1万円の昼ご飯食べるなよと言えますか？言えないでしょうに
バイトで生活している人の昼ご飯は 1万円だったら
これはもう異常欲でしょうに
異常欲というか異常バカでしょうに
でも  1万円っていうのはね
もう痛くも痒くもなく
の人々もいますから だからまあそういう風にあの人によって常識
異常識っていうことが区別してください
ノーマル欲はそんなに大げさな問題にはなりません
ノーマルはちょこっとずれたところでもう最悪状態になります
だからこの異常欲生まれちゃいますよ
みんなに これが心の汚れなんです
まあ例えば可愛い人と結婚して
子供もいて 家族は幸せで楽しいんだけど
なんか仕事をやっている間でもうちょっと可愛い人に出会った
出会いましたと それがすごく可愛くて
性格も良くて 自分が結婚していることも知っているのに
なかなか付き合ってくれると
そうすると じゃあこの人ももらったことにしようかと
どこかに別にセーフハウスを作って
そこで住んでもらっちゃうんですね
まあこれも欲がもう滑ったんですね
だから最初から仕事後
いろんな人間関係でいろんな美人に出会っても
自分が結婚しているんだっていうことははっきりと覚えておいて
そこのリミットを決めておかないと
たまにいいんじゃないっていうとダメなんです
そこで全部破れてしまいます
このたまにいいんじゃない？というところが
もう異常欲のもう始まりなんです
それでたまにいいんじゃないといった時点で
もう病気がほとんどもう発生しているんです
そこで気をつけるんじゃなくて
もっと先に気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
ためにいいんじゃないというのは
もう実行に決めています
実行しようと 実行しようと決める前に
結構頭の中でそこはいろんなことを企画立てていたんです
あの企画を立て始めた瞬間で
欲が異常欲に化けています
これが心の汚れで 人生は失敗する
何一つもうまくいかない
ヴィパッダ・チッタ・ウパッキレソ
ヴィパッダというのは瞋恚
害瞋 これは異常怒りですね
まあちょこちょこっと怒るっていうことはしょっちゅうあるんです
それが病気だとは思えません
時々怒らなかったら話聞いてくれない場合もあります
で そこはちょっとリミットを超えるとヴィパッダだって言うんですね
これは病気で怖いんです
害瞋ですね 次はコードー・チッタ・ウパッキレソ
怒りは心の汚れですと
で この場合はこの行動
怒りといっても これ かなり強い怒りなんで
軽く怒ってそうじゃないんです
そんなこと言うと怒りますよという程度じゃないんです
もうカッとなっちゃうんですね
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
その怒りなんです 次 ウパナーハ
これは怨恨ですね 時間を経ると怒りは怨恨になるんです
それで 4番目っていうのは
この まあ恨んでることですね
まず人は怒る いきなりカッとなっちゃう
このいきなりのあれ 噴火だから
それからそこを落ち着くはずなんです
瞬間に爆発しましたけど
それからどんどんどんどんどんどん落ち着いていくんで
地震と同じですね 地震と津波とかいきなり上がりますけど
それで一回で落ち着いてもらいますといういうことがなんですが
時々怒ったんだけど 怒りが消えない
この怒りが消えないことが恨みというものに変身しています
だからちょこちょこ起こることとは
これ随分怖いんです 不幸になります
必ず何もできなくなります
もう怒りが消えません
で 考えてください ちょっとしたことで怒ったんだけど
それから 1年経っても
2年経っても  4年経っても
20年経っても消えないんだったらどうしますかね
怒りは 消えない怒りもあるんです
それが人間に  5番目 マッコチッタッソウパッキレソ
偽善ですね この悪の何でしたっけ？これは腹蔵
で まあ悪を綺麗に隠しておくんです
といえば ほとんど人間がそれやってますね
だから私たちもね いつでももう失敗は人間しますけど
いつでもそれに言い訳持ってるんですね
言い訳持っていると もうダメですね
その人は成長しません
何やっても巧みに言い訳すると
悪人に決まってます その人も成長しないし
その人付き合ったらもう道連れになります
まあ仏教でのもっと汚いところなんですけど
すごく隠れて悪いことをしてして
それはもうあらゆる方法でまあ消しちゃう
消すっていうのは隠しておく
わからないようにしておく
この人々の この自分の悪を綺麗に隠す人々にはもう一つ性格があるんです
それでよくわかります
人の小さな罪でも もう
原子顕微鏡で見て巨大化して言いふらすんです
でも ちょっとしたことなんですけど
言うわ言うわ 言うわ言うわ
で  世間とかニュースとかね
見てみると 人の悪口ならまあ元気で言うこと
だからあまりにも他人の過ちをね
徹底追求するというね
証人喚問以外何も認めませんとかね
自認以外は何も認めませんという態度を取ると
言ってる人がもう人間として生きてる権利もないぐらい悪行為をしているんです
それは隠すためにやっているんです
だから人をけなした方が一番自分の立場を守れますよという俗世間のやり方なんですね
クタクタ批判したら 自分が立派やと思ってくれると
だから この末期の人々を発見した場合は
まあその人々は人の徳を見事に消すということも
それ逆に人のちっちゃな罪をね
派手に喋るということもあります
6番目 パラソ 他人の悪を軽視する
徳を軽視する 他人がどんないいことをしようとしたっても
そんなことって何のことないでしょうと言って
どうしてもケチをつけるんです
それも心の汚れなんですね
あの他人の良いことをいつでもバカにしてケチをつけると
自分の人生どうなるんですかね
自分が成功すると思う？この世の中で立派な人のことをすぐバカにする
例えば もう巨大のあのスーパーはチェーン店で経営している人がいる
経営者が もう一人の人が
まあそこにちょっとした店をね
ちょこちょこっと金借りて
なんとかちょっとした酒屋さんみたいな小さな店をやっていて
全然客も来ないし その人は堂々とあの経営者の悪口を言うとね
あんな商売なんかはね
どんな人にもできますよと
そんなやり方なら 彼が日本全国チェーン店持ったんだからって
なんだこれはと 商売ってのはこういう風にやるものではないかとかね
自分のこと じゃああんた 1
日売り上げは 2,000円やと
それで電気代とあれと計算したら
まあ電気代と家賃とかいたら 1
日まあ 8,000円ですけどね
それで1日 8,000円って 2,000円の売り上げでどうするんですかと
言うことを言いたいんだけど
そう言っちゃうと怒られるし
あの立派な経営者にむちゃくちゃ軽視する
ケチつける それって言って人生生きていられないでしょうに
我々はやっぱり立派な人から学ばなくちゃいけないっていうのは当たり前でしょうに
これがあると学べないんですね
これは では 私の勉強のための注釈書のところを書きましたけど
あの 他人のとこがいくら立派であったっても
ゴミのように扱うんだと
扱って捨てるんだと あるいは自分と同じだと思うんだと
だって私もそうでしょうと言うんです
はい  7番目の汚れは嫉妬ですね
8番目の汚れはマッチャリエ
これは物惜しみですね
あの この汚れっていうのは大体このペアでペアでで教えられています
その方がこの暗記しやすいんですよ
アビジャーとヴェーパーとアビジャー
ヴィサマロードウとヴェーパー
それからこのイッサー
マッチャリエ それはテストですね
それからマッコーパラーソ
それもセットなんです
同じものじゃないんだけど
なんとなくもうセットにすることはできます
イッサーっていうのは嫉妬でしょ
嫉妬っていうのは人のこと嫌なんですね
人のいいところは あれが自分にあってほしいと思うんです
だから人の幸福は その人ではなくて
自分にあった方が良かったんじゃないかと思うことが
まあ嫉妬なんですね だから嫉妬っていうのは当然仲間内で生まれます
皆様は一人も あのダメな菅さんよりは私が総理になった方がいいんじゃないかと
で 思わないでしょ 菅さんには嫉妬しません
しかし 菅さんの周りの人々は
もしかすると仲間がね
嫉妬する可能性はあります
鳩山さんも腹が立っている可能性はあります
仲間だから だから嫉妬っていうのは仲間同士で生まれるんです
人間っていうのは仲間で生活するでしょ
生まれてから死ぬまで
自分が何しようがね 一緒
でも仲間と一緒でしょ
仲間の間でこじけちゃうと
貧乏な人であろうとも
そこでもう仲間でいるし
貧乏な人はちょこちょこ頑張って頑張って金持ちになる時も仲間がいるし
まあ新しい仲間が増えたりもしますけど
だから死ぬ瞬間まで仲間と一緒にいるんです
そこで仲間とこじれるならば
もう話にならない それ時点で
だから嫉妬っていうのはとても危険な心の汚れなんです
仲間でない人のことは嫉妬しません
あ すげえと思うかもしれませんよ
テレビなんかでなんかすごい美人がいるんだぞとかね
すごい能力ある人がいるんだぞと見たら
すごいなと思うかもしれませんだけど
嫉妬は起きてこないんです
例えばスケーティングやっている
若い子たちが 日本代表になるかなと
代表にもなっていたところで
ソ連でもなんかなかなかの若者がいるんだぞとかね
話聞いてビデオを見たりすると嫉妬する可能性はあります
まずいな あの人は とかね
なんかなぜかというと
同じ舞台で競争する仲間でしょうに
しかし 私たちにとってはどうったことないんです
ソ連にもすごい人がいる
韓国にもすごい人がいるというと
まあやっぱりうちの子は勝ってほしいやと
日本から出る女の子が勝った方がいいなと思う程度で終わっちゃうんです
嫉妬まではいきません
しかし その同じレベルの人々は嫉妬する
だから嫉妬っていうのは相手の能力を私に欲しいということなんです
なんであなたにと これ私でしょうにと
それでもう人生成り立たなくなります
で マッチャリアっていうのは
そちらの反対で 自分の能力を他人と共有したくない
だったら勝手に生活してくださいと言うしかないんです
自分の能力っていうのは
共有するたびに売れるでしょうし
認められるでしょうに
それで生きるでしょうに
だから物惜しみっていうのは
生きることの正反対なんです
歌える人は歌ってあげなきゃ売れないでしょう
それまた喜んで一曲の歌ってくださいと頼まれたところで
まあついでにもう一曲歌ってあげますと
またリクエストもあったらもう一つやってあげますとね
かね 相手が一曲にはお金払ったんだけど
この人はもう三曲まで歌って帰っちゃうと
もう自分の能力はいっぱい共有しているでしょう
売れますよ その人々には払うお金がなくても
その人々はあの人すごい人ですよとかね
なんという人かと言うんだから
まあどこらでももう買っちゃいます
だから能力っていうのは共有するものなんです
最初からもう金にはなりません
なんとかして頑張って歌一つ書いたところで
ベストセラーになってほしいとか
なんかあの八八十 九十歳ぐらいのおばちゃまがね
もう書いた歌の本がね
まあベスト第 1位ね  2010年のね
第1位になってましたからね
これすごいことなんですけど
だからといって どんなおばあちゃんの書く歌はね
ベストセラーどころか売れませんよ
で やっぱりなんとなく歌を書いたところで
旦那さんに発表してみて
子供たちにも発表してみて
旦那に笑われちゃったら
もうちょっと腕上げなくちゃあかんとかね
あ これなかなかいいんじゃないかなと言ったら
なるほど いくらか腕上がったみたいとかね
そういうところから始めなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで とにかく能力っていうのは共有するものなんです
財産も共有するものなんです
人間が 特に現代人が それおかしいと思ってるんですね
だから現代人がもうもう全くもダメになっているんです
経済成長期 もうマイナスでしょ
今は  9番目 マーヤ これあの詐欺
ごまかし 欺くですね なんとかごまかしてごまかしをして自分の利益を取ろうとする
それも心の汚れなんですね
で まあその都度その都度うまくいくかもしれませんよ
詐欺はうまくいったと
しかし 人の成功成長はどうなるんですかね
自分がごまかすことしか考えない場合は
すぐ自分が同じ能力のない汚れた汚い心でいなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
能力があるとごまかさなくてもいいでしょうに
詐欺やらなくてもいいでしょうに
だから詐欺のプロになっちゃうと絶対能力は向上しません
一回だけでも詐欺的な行為をやったならば
それはもう自分の能力を成長させませんという意味になっちゃうんです
だから能力より高いものの位置に行ったんだから
それからはもう成り立ちませんよ
例えば人の成績表を自分の名前入れ替えたりして
どこかの大学に出す まあよくやることですけどね
大学は成績を見たら この人すごくいい人だと
じゃあこの大学で研究していただきますと
それであなたはもう合格やと
そこで自分にふさわしいこんな位置に入ったでしょうね
それからどうする？という問題なんです
10番目 サーテーヤ  へつらい
するがしこいということですね
だから能力向上を考えてないんですね
なんとかするがしこいことをやって
このするがしこいっていうことを漢字を見たんだところで
なんか何て言ったっけ？漢字は
狐の知恵という漢字なんですね
知恵と狐なんです  狡猾ですか
え？狡猾 なんとかそれ
狡猾なんとかですね  狡猾じゃない
えっ？ 狡猾  狡猾  狡猾は結構
狡猾 それから漢字見て面白かったんです
だからそういうね へつらいやってうまくいったっていうことは
能力はないということになるんですね
能力いらんぞっていうことで
これは心の汚れになるんです
11はたんぼ 頑固 まあ頑固だったらそこでストップなんですね
固定したんだからね あの
仏教ではこれは面白い喩えでね
何かきつい鉄の棒を飲み込んでいるんだと
長い棒を飲み込んでいて
鉄の棒が曲がりませんね
体が そんな感じで もう人の話は聞かない
環境には曲がれない 滑らかじゃない
それで終わりということになります
12番目 結構ありますね
汚れ サーランボ これ張り合うことですね
いつでも喧嘩を売ってくる性格
何も言えない ちょっと言ったらなんだっていう風にかかってくるんですよ
だからいつでも 例えば自分が何にでもかかっていくぞと思っちゃうと
何も勉強しないでしょ
自分が相手いうことに喧嘩売っちゃえばいいと思っているんだから
そういう性格もあります
それはもう人間の成長も成功も幸福も壊すんです
たまたまもう張り合った方がいいケースあるかもしれませんだけど
これはもうすごい万が一出てくるだけであって
人生は張り合い人生になっちゃうと
もうとんでもない不幸なやつなんですよ
13番目はマーナですね
慢 慢っていうのは自分中心に測るんですね
それともう一つ 別にいっそでもマナーをアティマナーとセットにするんで
お釈迦様は マナーはもう一応誰にでもあります
まあ自分という意識が強いということなんですね
自我意識がちょっと ちょっと強すぎ
いわゆる気にしすぎ だから自我を自分ということが気にしちゃうと慢になっちゃうんです
ちょっとこれが足かせになるんですよ
まあ誰でも自分のことは気にしてますけど
それはちょっとでもちょっと気にしすぎちゃうと
マナーというんですね
確実に障害になるんです
もう何もできなくなります
アティマナっていうのは別バージョンですね
これが俺が偉いという態度なんです
俺が偉い あんた方何や？という態度
だからマナ アティマナという 2つもペアにしなくちゃいけない
同じことではないかではないんです
慢と高慢 この下慢とか卑下慢とか何とかもう一つ単語がありますけど
それはこのリストから抜けてます
何か理由があったでしょうと思います
瞑想やら心清らかにする修行の場合はそこも使いますけど
今はこのリストからまあ卑下慢
まあよくわからない まああまりまずそんなにもないんで
みんな傲慢ありすぎですからね
だから傲慢 ちょっとありすぎ
卑下慢というのはたまにあるんですけど
まあだからってそんなに大きな社会問題は作りません
ただ能力はあるにあるんだけど
やってくれないんですね
もう後ろ下がるんですね
いいいい もうまあ別の人頼んでくださいとかね
まあそれでも強引にやりなさいと言っちゃうと
なんとかやってくれることもあります
だからまあ そこは障害としては入ってないんですね
15マドー 16はパマドというまたセットなんですね
マドーというのは怠ることですね
何ですかね これ 欲があるんですからね
調子に乗ってるんですね
興奮状態で まだっていうのは言葉だけ見ると酔ってる状態なんですね
あの酔っ払いが あのものすごいボロボロよ
ボロボロというんですか
このものすごく酔った時ではなくて
なんとなく程よい 酔っちゃったらどうなる？結構調子に乗ってるでしょ
人間っていうのはいつでもそんな状態でいるともうダメなんですね
なんか周り状況っていうのはわからなくなりますね
ですから このまあ だから怠るんですね
次はまあ十六はパマードゥ
それは放逸という これはあのブッダのすごい厳しい専門用語ではあります
パマードゥはすごい説明しなくちゃいけない単語で
あの あのヴィパッサナー瞑想をする時はこれに挑戦するんですね
この心の汚れのリストたくさんありましたけど
十六を壊そうとしているんです
この十六を壊しちゃうと
他の汚れは全部落ちるんです
だからこの汚れに使う洗剤で他の汚れも全部落ちるんです
今までの十五番目の汚れには適当な洗剤あります
そこで十六になってくると
使うべき洗剤ではもう全部消えますから
だったら初めからそれ使っちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
洗剤はたくさん種類使うよりも
初めからそれ使っちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
全部決まってるしと だからパマードの反対はこのヴィパッサナー実践やってる時
紹介している気づき 今の瞬間に気づいている
今何が起きているかと知っている
現在に目が覚めている
現実に目が覚めている状態なんです
その反対は現実ではふざけているということなんです
だからたまに惑ってなんかふざけるっていうふうな意味なんですね
いつふざけるの楽しいんだけど
危険なんですね いつでもふざけている場合じゃないでしょうに
仏教はふざけることは全然ダメやと
どんな瞬間でも真剣に現実に目覚めていなさいと
ふざけるんじゃなくて
明るければいいでしょうに
ふざける人っていうのは明るくないんだから
ふざけて強引に人工的な明るさ作るんです
だから常に明るければいいのにね
はい 十六で終わります
汚れた布が美しい色で染めることはできないように
心にこの汚れがあるとき
成長させることはできないんです
これはお釈迦様が使った例えで
経典は服に例えているんですね
布に 布っていうのは もし自分が好きな色で美しい服をデザインしたければ
布もともと綺麗でなければダメなんです
汚いグリースとかね 油汚れとかある布はもう色は染めないんですね
そういうことで 心の汚れはこの経典
今日使っている経典では十六あります
この番号で覚えた方がいいんです
その方が自己管理しやすいんです
あの十六という番号はどうでもいいんですけど
最初からもうアビッジャ
ウェーパード コードー
ウパナーホ マッキー パラーソというふうに覚えた方が
だからなぜかというと
こちらは汚れのあらかるてだから
いつその都度その都度何か汚れが出てくるんですね
イッチャイッサーマッチャリ
欲も嫉妬も出てきて 次に物惜しみも出てきたりとかね
だからその都度その都度
あ これは今 この汚れ この汚れ
この汚れやと と確認するためにリストを覚えておくんです
だから暗記 日本訳は暗記できるようにできているかどうかよくわからないんだけど
私はその目的で訳していないし
パーリ語はもう暗記するためにできているんです
パーリ語をちょこっと知ってる人なら
まあそんなもうちょっと 15 分ぐらいちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこっと繰り返して言うと
もう暗記になります そういう見事な学問的
学教育的なからくりも裏あるんです
はい 我々は 16 の汚れがあると覚えておいて
生きてる上でどんな汚れがログインするかわからないでしょ
この汚れを確認するんです
汚れでログインしたら
その仕事は失敗する この汚れリストはなんとか何か
なんて言いますか 自分のパスワードと思ってください
ID とパスワード みんな狂ったような感じで TWITTER やらいろいろ書いてるでしょ
私は書きませんだけど
だからもう FACEBOOK やら TWITTER やら
いろんなものにもうマイスペースとかね
ありましてね 日本だけのミキというサイトもありますし
まああちらこちらでそれぞれ自分がアクセスしてはいけない ID
とパスワードは 16 持っていて
知らないうちにそこにアクセスしたところで
あ これだったらダメやとはっきりと覚えておいた方が身の安全なんです
この 16 の ID パスワードでではアクセスしてはいけませんと
これでインターネットではなくて世界にアクセスするんです
世界にアクセスする 生きることにアクセスする
生きることにアクセスするときは
このパスワードは使わないこと
普通はみんなそのパスワードいくつかで 16 もしっかりと持っている人もいますよ
もう最悪もう犯人になっちゃうんですね
あの鳥取駅とかね そういうところで事故を起こした人とかね
事件を起こした人とかね
それは行動とウパナーヒでしょう
怒りと恨みとかね そこでアクセスしたんですね
世間に 人生にアクセスしたところで
人を刺して終わっちゃったんですね
とても大事なことは 汚れを発見することです
汚れを発見したらもう解決したと思っても構いませんよ
難しい 我々はものすごい詐欺師なんです
マヤーもあるんです へつらいもあるんですよ
だからもうごまかすんです
あの人は嫉妬するんだけどね
人のことばっかり言うんです
あの人はね 結構詐欺的なことばっかりでしょうと
よくダラダラと 言うと
自分のことどうですかね
３番目と ４番目に当たってますけど
で あの 私たちはこのどうもこの一番引っかかっているのは
このおそらくあのマーヤということとサーテイヤということだと思いますね ８
と９と１０ですね この 9番目はね
で マーヤ これあの 自分でもごまかしちゃうんです
あの 5番目はあのよりではないんです ５
番目っていうのは あの
もう悪いことをしたら
これはやっぱりなんとかごまかしておかないとまずいと思っちゃうんだから
あの それと違う思いますよ
この 9番目のマーヤは
これ ちょっとなんかすごい隠れて行動して
いつでもなんか自分いい人間のように見せて見せて生きてるんですね
だから自分に悪いことあると
もう見たくもないんです
だからそんなものあるんだから
この私たちにはこの ちょっと直しづらいというところもあります
そういうことで この発見しましょう
それでも問題は九十パーセント解決しましたと
すぐ発見できる 今このパスワードになっちゃったと言った途端
そこのもうパスワード使わなくなっちゃうんです
それから汚れないように気をつけますという正直な意欲が必要です
ただ決めればいいんです
この汚れないようにしますと
この汚れたパスワードではアクセス生きることにアクセスしませんと
気をつけますという意欲があれば
心は心汚れなくなります
すごい簡単でしょ 心きれいにするのは
あの意欲さえあればいいんです
でも 意欲あっただけじゃダメです
だから世の中で誰でも思ってるでしょ
きれいな心作りたいやばとかね
言ってる人はいくらでもいますよ
なんでできないかというと
このリストを持ってないんです
このリストを作るのはブッダ以外できないんです
ブッダすべてのことを知り尽くしましたから
もうリスト作れます だからそこでリストを覚えておいて
あ 今これやとわかっちゃうと OK
それで治ります 簡単に
この実践を続けて行うと
長い時間清らかさを保つことができるようになります
そこで 1 日ではなくて
1週間  2週間  1ヶ月  1年
2年  3年 一生とかね この同じ実践を続けてみる １６
覚えておいて 気をつけて
あ これはダメ あ これはやめます
これもやめます とか 嫉妬が出てくる
嫉妬はダメと言った途端
嫉妬消えるんです なんかすごい害心が出てきたら
害心ではね 生きることにアクセスしてはいけませんと思っただけで
その瞬間害心が消えるんです
そこで無事その問題は通過します
またいきなり異常欲が生まれて生まれたくるで
あ 異常欲がダメ これ第1
異常欲で人生にアクセスしませんと思った途端
異常欲が消える 便利なもんですよ
リストさえ持っておけば
このリストと気をつけますという意欲
こんな簡単な話はね 世の中でないんです
だから皆さんもすっごいややこしい複雑な方法あるんだと
厳しい苦行 修行が必要でしょうとかね
思わないでください このちょろいもんですよ
清らかな心を作るということは
まずリストを覚えておいて
その都度その都度発見します
パスワード それから汚れませんと意欲を持っている
だから へつらいなことをやりたくなった瞬間で
へつらいでね 人生にアクセスするんじゃないやと思ったら消える
一時的ですよ また出ますよ
一時的でもすーっと消しているんだから
この人の計算してみると
結構清らかな心で  1ヶ月とか 2ヶ月とかも
1年ももういたことになってるんです
だから時間かけてやるということはそういうことなんです
やっと 15年で卒業しましたではないんです
この経験を積み重ねるんです 1
日  2日  1週間  1ヶ月  2ヶ月のように努力する
心は清らかさに慣れてしまうんです
それでなんとなくもう慣れちゃったことになるんです
もう嫉妬は出てこなくなって
怒り 瞋恚 害意が出てこなくなりまして
害心とかね 詐欺の気持ちとかね
なかなか出てこなくなっちゃって
傲慢もないし 慢もないし
怠ることもなくて 不放逸もなくなったと
不放逸も しっかりしてもう明るくなっているんです
だから慣れなんですね
清らかさに慣れると 仏法僧にすべて確信が生じるんですよ
この方法はブッダが教えたんだからね
世界でどこにでもないんです
心を清らかにする道というのはね
こんな心理学的に信仰はひとかけらも使わないで
明確な理性に基づいて解れたことっていうのは
どんな心理学者にも不可能なんです
どんな宗教家にもできないんです
これがブッダだからこそ教えられたんです
そうすると ブッダの智慧がやっぱりすごいものだと自分で経験で知ってますよ
それでこの人どうしますかね
ブッダの他の教えもちょこちょことだけでもやった方がいいんだと
これはもう間違いなしと
見事に正しいんだという信頼感が生まれてくるんです
それから仲間といえば
仏道を実践する人々こそ私が尊敬するべき仲間ではないかと
私は模範にするべき モデルにするべき仲間っていうのは
まあそうではないかということで
仏法僧に対する信頼感が生まれるんです
仏教ではそういう実験して証拠を出したところで生まれる信頼に信仰と言うんです
だから宗教的信仰ではないんです
名前は似ていますけど
ものすごい中身が違うんです
何の葛藤もなく真理を理解することも
実践することもできるようになってくるんです
清らかな社会の仲間に入っているんです
もうこの時点になってくると
自分がもう仲間入りしている
清らかなグループのあなたも入ってもいいよと
その社会にね いわゆるブッダの社会ですね
ブッダの仲間にもう入ることはもう受理されてされて OK になっているんです
すごい 仏教はアリアの仲間
アリアっていうのは聖人
インテリですね いわゆる
まあそのグループの一員にもなっているんです
真理を知ることができるようになります
それからもう仲間に入れてもらったら
なんのことなく真理は他の真理も知ることができるようになります
真理を知ると楽しみが生じます
これ次のステップなんですよ
心の汚れなくなったら
本当のことを次から次へと発見するんです
生命に対して この本当のことを発見すると
すごい面白いんですよ
皆さんはそうでしょう
いろいろ研究して 何か新しいものが発見すると
ものすごい楽しいでしょ
時々みんな考古学ごっこもやってるでしょ
あっちこっち行って掘るんですね
穴を 穴を掘ったところで
ちょっと何か破片見つかったら
前一番あったんですね
こういう恐竜の化石を探すというね
いろんなところへ行って
ちょっと何かもうなんとか恐竜の歯が見つかりましたとかね
まあ喜ぶこと やっぱり発見っていうのは喜びなんですよ
ああいうくだらんものを発見してあれほど喜びますから
人生にすぎて真理を発見すると
ものすごいもう信じられない喜びが生まれてくるんです
この楽しみから喜びという漢字とか使ってますけど
楽しみですね この楽しみから喜びが生じます
この仏教はやっぱり楽しみにランクをつけてあります
まず楽しみ それから喜びというね
まあ楽しみっていうのはどちらかというと脳的ですね
脳が興奮する程度ですね
このこちらで書いた喜びっていうのは
脳だけではなくて もう全体的にもう湧いてくる
喜びなんです それで体が軽くなっちゃうんですよ
脳だけじゃないんですね
例えばゲームなんかやってると楽しいでしょ
その時 脳細胞の一部だけ刺激するんですね
それは楽しいんだけど
体がむちゃくちゃ痛くなっていくんです
目も痛くなってくるんですね
もうなんか不機嫌になってしまうんですね
日常生活もうまくいかなくなっちゃう
大変危険なんですね その場合は
しかし いろんなことを学んで楽しみが生まれると危険性ないでしょ
何か学んで発見して楽しくなったら
なんかすごく楽しくて
ニコニコとみんなにもニコニコと顔を見せて
なんだ あなたやけに今日楽しそうで
今日はね こういうこと見つかりましたよとかね
相手にも言うでしょうに
だからもう社会性は消えてないんです
ゲームなどの楽しみの場合は
社会性はもう犠牲になっちゃうんです
それから 自分の人生の幸福も犠牲にするんですね
この楽しみの次 幸福 喜びというものが出てくるんです
喜びっていうのは 肉体
体まで喜びを感じる そうすると体がすごい軽くなっていくんです
この体軽くなることっていうのは
瞑想には必要なんです
瞑想すると足が痛くて
腰が痛くて 背中が痛くて
肩が肩が凝ってとかね
そういう状態では集中力が生まれません
なんか体がなんか八方逸るのような感じになってくるんです
すごい軽くなるんです
軽くて滑らかい 肉体が
座りたい場合はドカンと座れます
足を組んだっても なんかゴムでできているような感じで
シリコンゴムでできているような感じで
何のことなく組める 背骨伸ばそうといったら
もうシリコンゴムだからしっかりと伸ばします
全くも重さがないんです
硬さがないんです これなら見事にサマーディが生まれます
はい そこが過程 成長過程なんです
だから最初に心の汚れを時間かけてチェックする
それでどんどん見事に仏法僧についての確信が信頼が出てきて
真理発見することになっちゃって
ブッダの仲間にも入れてもらって
これですごいまた真理発見しちゃって
喜びがむちゃくちゃ感じちゃって
で 体も軽くなってサマーディまで作れる
もう言うことない このサマーディ作れることまで必要なんですね
だから心が汚れがある限り何もできない
ただそれだけ すぐにどうしようかなとやることなくなっちゃう
楽しいんですよ 人生は
苦しみ消えちゃった もうほとんどないんですね
はい それでどうしようもないんだから
慈悲喜捨の実践が始まるんですね
その人は宮廷に贅沢なごちそうを食べても心が揺らがないんですと
お釈迦様はわざとそのポイントを入れてるんです
このサマーディまで達した人が
社会的に修行しなくてもいいんです
社会はもう頭剃ってないと
特別な服を着ていないと
特別な食事習慣ないと
特別な場所で住んでいないと
なんか修行者じゃないやと言うでしょうに
あんな愚か者に乗る必要はないんです
頭に何か変なものを被って
それから法螺貝 でっかい法螺貝でも持って
長い杖を持って もう白い服を着てとかね
わらじを履いて もうあれやこれやと大騒ぎすると
ああすごいな この修験道さんとかね
すがりたい あやかりたいと思ってやるし
だからそんなの愚か者の世界なんですよ
形で判断するとかに お釈迦様そんなのはいらんやと言いたいんですね
だからこのプロセスで心をしっかり綺麗になった人が
ものすごい贅沢 ごちそうをいただきます
究極のごちそう 贅沢 でも大丈夫です
心は冷静に揺らがない心なんです
お釈迦様も弟子たちも
もうそっちを宮殿にまで行きますよ
王様が立ちすんでいる
宮殿に行ったら 宮殿で王様自分の手でごちそうを差し上げたりするんです
宮殿にはね まあ中国もそうでしょうに
人が入るのはものすごい難しいでしょうね
入っても女性たちには会うことはできません
顔を合わせることは禁止
仏弟子たちが行ったら
お妃たちでもざーっと揃ってきて
まあお世話したりする
王様も何も思いません
じゃあもう国にいる一番立派な美人たちに会ったんだからといって
何かなるかともなんともないんですね
心は微塵も揺らぎません
それで安定した心 汚れない心もとっくに作っています
誘惑に対して心配する必要はなくなるんです
で それから 東西南北上下という六方に無制限に広がる慈悲喜捨の実践を行うんです
慈悲喜捨 それで本物できるんです
皆さんも慈悲の瞑想やってるでしょ？まあ本物じゃないでしょうね
ハハハ 本物はすごい強力なんですよ
もう奇跡的な能力を持っています
もうものすごい力を持ってます
慈悲の瞑想 だから心清らかになっちゃうと
正直に東の方 無限にどんな生命でも幸福でありますようにと
西の方 無限にすべての生命が幸福でありますようにと
東西南北上下とかね まあそれは表現であって
自分 すべての生命は自分なりのやり方で実践すればよろしいんですけど
一応これは包括的に語れますから
お釈迦様は この六方を使うんですね
しかし 東西南北という六方じゃないんです
前 後 右 左 上 下なんです
東西南北ではないんです
これはもう日本語になってくると東西南北だと思っただけ
私は 本当は前後左右 上上下下なんです
ここに存在がいて 前の存在
後ろの存在 左の 右の 上の
下の 無限に自分から慈しみの波動を広げるんです
自我エゴのない気持ちでいても
さらに上があると発見するんです
この慈悲の瞑想をすると
もう自我がなくなりますね
自分という存在がどんどん広がっていっちゃいますからね
消えちゃいますね 他の生命と一緒に溶けてしまっちゃって
自と他の区が区別消えちゃいます
消えても なんとなくやっぱりこれより上の方ない
あるみたいだなと感じちゃうんです
この一体感だけでは レベルが低いんだと
もっと上があるんだと
それで発見するんですね
それで上に挑戦するんですね
それで簡単に解脱に達するんです
一切の生命と自と他の区別消えたところで終わりじゃないんです
解脱ってもうステップあります
それに達するんです それで洗濯無用
注意無用の心が現れるんです
それからもう洗濯はいらん
もう汚れません 汚れるのは不可能という心が作れます
それで究極的に安心です
その人がやるべきことは全部やって終わりましたよと
修行はすべてやって終わりましたよと
もう卒業だと いう やり終えたという楽しみ
充実感 あれ すごいことでしょ
何か大きな仕事をやってうまく終わったらすごい楽しいでしょ
あのつどい 仕事をして終わった瞬間のあの喜びがすーっと残るんです
はい まあそんな程度ですね
心の洗濯は はい 今日は皆様もクリスチャンになっているんだから
できるだけ遠慮しようかなと思っていましたけど
これ私のせいじゃないんです
経典のちょこっと尾っぽの尾っぽがあるんです
で この話を聞いていたんです
お釈迦様がこのここでちょっとした単語を使ったんです
あのすんだりかバーラドゥワジャというバラモン人が邪教外道なんですけど
話を聞いていたんですね
はい その尾っぽの話に入ります
一神教は人間の力では罪は消えない
神の赦しが必要だと説くんです
あの日本ではないでしょうと思いますけど
この国々で アメリカでもありますね
あの 罪を犯して あの処刑とかなんとかに決めた人々に
大統領とかね 特別あれ
何て言いますかね え？恩赦
許すことですか うん 恩赦です
恩赦 はい 恩赦しかないと
一神教はみんなそう言ってるんですよ
その主観が自分の国でもありますけど
この犯罪を起こしてもう死刑に決めたら
まあ大統領は好き勝手に誰かあの人
あの人 あの人を恩赦にしますとかね
決めたらまあ処刑はしませんし
20年ぐらい刑務所にいて
また家に戻っちゃうんですね
アメリカ大統領も結構やりますけど
しかし 刑務所にはむちゃくちゃたくさんの人々がいるでしょうに
恩赦に預かるためにわざわざと自分の名前を売り込むことっていうのは大変でしょ
刑務所の人にとっては
だから その人を知っている人々が
ものすごい金持ちで影響力ある人々がいるならば
いろいろ活動して なんかいろんなことをやって宣伝して
まあもうこの際 もう大統領の恩赦にこの人をお願いしますと
と提供したところで その中で大統領はまあ 10人に決めたんだからと
で  10人選ぶで リストに 15人いたっても
5人の名前は消されますでしょうに
だから恩赦に預かるということ
相当難しいんです また
犯罪を起こした人々には誰も親切じゃないでしょう
しかし この麻薬のドンとかね
かなりの凶暴な人々とかね
犯罪を犯したと刑務所で裁判で罰を受けても
金があるんだからね 仲間がいるんだから
政治家に金出してるんだから
それで恩赦をもらっちゃいます
自分の国でも 今の政府ではなくて
こと前々前ぐらい もうとんでもない政府がいて
ヤクザみたいな人がいて
若い者でしたけど ものすごい犯罪を起こすんですね
なかなかもう捕まっても政治家が解放しなさいと言うんだから
警察はもう調べることもできないんです
しかし 一回はこの女の子を犯して
これはスリランカ人がものすごい厳しいんです
子供のことになってくると
もうかなり厳しいんです
子供には世界でどこでも自由に遊んで生活するようにしておかなきゃというか
誰でも大人がすごい厳しく守ってあげるんです
だから子供の女の子を犯しちゃうとね
もう刑務所 政府に警察に対処されなかったら
一般人があの人を投げ下すと思いますよ
それぐらい怖いんです
で その場合は警察も人間だから
いくらなんでもこれはダメやと思って
もう政治家の話を聞かないで
もう逮捕して裁判かけてもう
もう有罪になっちゃったんです
大統領はのこのこと恩赦で自由にしちゃったんです
で その党も選挙で負けたんです
今でも偉そうなこと言った途端
そういうケースみんな出すんです
あんた方 今更国民のために泣くのかいと
こんなことやった連中ではないかと
大変ですよ もうもう だからこの言いたかったのは
恩赦をもらうということは
そういう何かコネがあった人にはできますけど
何もコネもなく ただ単にもう自分がバカだから罪を犯した人にとっては
もう誰も訴えてこないんですよ
だから私は言いたいのは
あの神の恩赦で以外 恩赦以外
赦し以外 罪は消えませんというと
これ大変な仕事になります
私が今まで説明したような
こんなちょろいもんやっていうことじゃないんです
言ったでしょ 心を清らかにすると
そんなちょろいやと リスト
リストもポケットに入れておいて
今これやとね 暗記するのはできないんだったら
リストをポケットに入れておけば
だって 16でしょうに
気持ちが悪くなった瞬間にリストを見て
はい  7番 また入れて それだけです
あ 今 今 11番 で またポケットに入れておく
その瞬間で消えます それが 1年
2年やってみると まあ見事に心も清らかになっているし
仏教の世界にももう仲間入りしているんです
それから真理は次から次へと発見していくんです
で 解脱にも達します そういう簡単な方法なのに
恩赦が割り込んでくると赦しが割り込んでくると
一部の稀な人しか救われないということになるんです
沐浴で罪を清らかにするという信仰はバラモン教にもあったんです
あのバラモン教っていうのは
まあ一応バラモン教と今言うんだけど
学問的にはね ヴェーダ教
ヴェーダ信仰とかね とも言いますしね
バラモン教というあんまり専門学問
学術的な用語はあんまりないんですけどね
ヴェーディックリリジアンという言葉を使いますけどね
このいわゆる紀元前 3000年
4000年ほど前から
水によって清めると あの古代文明のモヘンジョダロとハラッパとかインドにありますね
あちらにもあるんです
宗教みたい まだよくわからないんだけど
水で清めるというね だからアーリア文明の以前からあった習慣なんです
釈尊は心の洗濯プログラムを比丘シナートアンタレーナシナネーナというちょっとしたフレーズを使ったんですね
お釈迦様のなんか習慣みたいですね
何か説法して 何かちょっと一つ一言葉覚えられる
なんか昨日聞いた言葉一つ言うんですね
それがシナートアンタレーナシナネーナ
このアンタレーナシナネーナという言葉がですよ
美しい言葉はアンタレーナというのは内観的
いわゆる心の中を見ることですね
心の中を見ることで洗礼を受けるんだと
沐浴するんだと だからお釈迦様
あのインドアーリア文化になる以前
古代文明の時からもあった宗教習慣を
その言葉を使っちゃったんです
しかし その水で体心洗うんじゃなくて
中身見ることで内観することで洗っちゃえと
これがすごい簡単だよって説いたんですね
それ聞いたの スンダリーバラモンが
釈迦様も沐浴 沐浴 洗礼をしますかと
この洗礼という言葉入っちゃったんだから
お釈迦様もそこら辺 ガヤという川があったんです
お釈迦様はガヤといったところで沐浴なさいます？と聞いたところで
この野郎 勘違いのいいところやとお釈迦様は思ったでしょうね
これからむちゃくちゃ言うんですよ
愚か者が黙欲洗礼をすると
それはね 愚か者がやりますよと
洗礼は バーフカンアディカッカンチャガヤン
スンデリカンマピサラスセティンパヤガンチャアトバーフマティンナディンニッチャンバーローパッカンドカンナカンモネスジェティ
意味は この川の名前なんですね
バーフカ アーディッカカ
ガヤ スンデリカ マヒ サラッセティ
ブーマティなどの川に愚か者が飛び込むが
犯した悪行為から清らかにはなりませんと
これ仏教笑っちゃいますよ
ちょっと洗礼を受けたんだから罪がなくなりましたとかね
これわざと書くのは 私は手紙がもらってね
手紙で私にはいろいろ注意があってね
キリスト教を批判するとか
もっと丁寧にいい加減ふざけて言わないでくださいと
言ったら 私はやっぱりふざけさが足らなかったなとかね
もっとむちゃくちゃふざけた方が
私はただ冗談を取るために言ってるだけで
どうも関係ないんですからね
どうったことないんです
その手紙にイエス様もね
死ぬほど苦しい洗礼を受けたんだよと
洗礼を受けるということは死ぬことぐらいのことだと
あれあれと思ったんですね
ただ 水にちょっと入れてもらうことがそんなに怖いことですかね
もしかすると水の中に30分 1
時間ぐらい放り込んでおくんですかね
私もそういうふうにキリスト教の人を洗礼してあげたいんですね
深いどこかに水に入れて
首に4080キロぐらいの重さを入れて
水にかけて 30分ぐらい待ってから上げてあげると
罪が消えていると 私はあの人の手紙に返事書きたかったんだけど
やっぱり私も死ぬ思いで洗礼を受けたいんだと
これであの あの子供性的虐待した神父さんたちを捜してますよと
あの連中に洗礼を受けたってもね
何の清らかなこともしないね
人をマインドコントロールするし
洗脳するし 脅すし 自分たちが究極な贅沢するし
まあそれでちょっと水をかけちゃうと
まあ罪が消えるという
すごい原始的なことなんです
だから面白いことって
これはキリスト教の文化に盗まれた話で
モヘンジョダロハラッパ時代からもう人間が水に飛び込んだら罪が消え
洗えますよと思っていたんだから
大したことないでしょうに
イランにあったあの何とかというゾロアスター教ですね
まあそちらも火を拝むとかね
ゾロアスター教の開祖様もバージンで生まれたんです
だから神の子がバージンで生まれるということは
もうそろいもそろって教から
それは今現在世界にある一番古い教教でしょ
自分のオリジナルって何もないんですね
ヒンドゥー教にもオリジナル的ないくらかあるし
いくらか微妙にあります
仏教は完璧にオリジナルで
何一つも借りた教えがないし
ジャイナ教もオリジナル的なものはあって
ユダヤ教 イスラム教 キリスト教と
この第3巨大な三宗教にはひとかけらもオリジナル的なものはないんです
そんな事実ですからね
偉そうなことを言っちゃうと
もうむちゃくちゃ言いますよ
だからお釈迦様はもうむちゃくちゃ言ったんですよ
すごい厳しいんだけど
言葉はね 厳しいと言ったってお釈迦様からかってますからね
だからものすごい勇猛だから
お釈迦様は でってことで
ちょっと省略しました
一切の生命に安穏を抱くこと
ことという洗礼を今ここで行いなさいと
だからお釈迦様が言うのはもう洗礼なんです
しかし その洗礼っていうのは
今ここ一切の生命に対して安穏を抱きなさいと
いわゆる慈しみを持ちなさいと
それでもう洗礼だと 洗礼っていうのは罪が消える行為なんです
キンカーハシガヤンガンとはウドパーノーティテーガヤ
これ最後になった ガヤ川に行って何をすると
水飲むことでしょうに
あれ 水飲むところでしょうにと
水を飲むとかなったら
もう川に行って 昔はね
川の水を飲めたんだからね
水をちょっとこうね あんた罪まで洗うのかと
インドは未だにやってますよ
あのガヤというところでね
もう NHK でももう大祭りで
もう放送しますよ あの水に川に飛び込んで
太陽の方を見て呪文唱えるは
また中に入ってまた開けてまた呪文唱えるとかね
それであの川の水を持っていって飲んだりもします
あの喉が渇いてるからじゃなくて
罪を清らかにするためなんです
一体罪って何やと思ってるんですかね
この連中は なんで具体的にみんな罪っていうのは嘘言うことでしょうに
嘘を言ってからもう体に水を振りかかってもらったら
はい 消えたって なんだこれ
人でも殺して そのまま勢いでガンジス川に飛び込めばいいんです
だから私には飛び込むならば
首に腰にでもいいんだから
重りで持って飛びなさいよと
それだったらなんとか
その罪がなんとかなるでしょうと
だからあまりにも迷信原始的なんですよ
洗礼儀礼は そこでこの今ここというところはポイントなんですね
心の洗濯に巡礼も聖地もいりません
今ここで始めれば良いんです
今ここで始まっていれば
それでスタートなんです
スッダセウェサダーパッグ
清らかな人には 毎日が心清らかにする整備ですね
特別なお盆みたいに お正月みたいに宗教の目覚める特別な日が馬鹿馬鹿らしいんです
心清らかなならば するならば
どんな時間でも大丈夫です
どんな日でも素晴らしい日なんです
毎日が修行の日です 儀式
儀礼 祭り日などは仏教に関係ないんです
心の洗濯は簡単に始まれます
始められます 心の洗濯ならすぐ始めればいいんです
何もいらん ただリストをね
書いてポケットに入れてチェックするだけ
はい まあもう時間になりましたからね
そこら辺終了したいと思いますけど
えーとまあいろいろ心清らかにする
またいくつかの方法ありまして
まああまり長くないんで
そこも読み上げて終わりますます
洗濯する方法はたくさん説かれています
だからいろんな経典で
いろんな方法でね 心清らかにする方法っていうのはあります
例えば怒りを収める場合は
有名な鋸の話あるでしょ
だからノコギリで切られても怒りませんよと決めておきなさいと
そうすると怒りが収める
それは怒りだけですね
他の他の修行の人であっても
欲が生まれたらこうしますよとかね
いろいろあります 誰にでもできる方法は道徳を守ることですね
一番簡単なことといわれ
誰にでもできることは道徳なんですね
道徳を守り始めると 心はきれいになり始めるんです
いわゆる殺生しない 嘘言わない
邪な行為しないとかね
盗まないとかね 麻薬酒は使わないとかね
始めたら その瞬間から心は汚れからきれいになっていくんです
思考を管理することも一つですね
だから汚れて 罪っていうのは心で生まれるんだから
思考を管理する 何でもかんでもいい加減で思考しないことにする
上手な運転手は 運転を管理するように
気をつけるように 思考を気をつけて運転するんです
乱暴な無法な運転はしない
そのように乱暴で無法でいい加減で思考しないということをすれば
見事にまたきれいになるんです
悪思考を強引に止めて善思考で置き換えるんですね
そのやり方は 悪 悪思考が生まれたら強引にストップさせて
ブレーキかけて これは行き止まりやと
で 善思考思考でいくんです
理性を重んじることも良い方法です
また 理性の人間である
鵜呑みにすることをやめちゃって
恐れ多いとかやばいとか
神様にからかったら罰が当たるとか
ああいう迷信全部捨てちゃって
現実的に生きてみるんです
たとえローマ教皇でも
言ったことをおかしいんだったらおかしいよと
言っちゃえば その自由はね
だから理性が必要なんですね
ただ言っただけではダメですよ
ちゃんと理性に基づいて
こういうこういうことで
これはおかしいと 自分と他人の幸福を目指して生きる
生きてみると決めることでも
人の生き方が汚れない方向へ変わります
あるいは人生論を作る
我は管理管理者になるそうではなくて
私は人の役に立つ人間になりますと
勉強するときでも 勉強してから職業を探すときでも
職業仕事をするときでも
自分の幸福と人の幸福を考えて生きてみる
たったそれ決めただけでも大丈夫です
それから全部変わってきます
心はきれいになります
お釈迦様おっしゃるどんな方法でも
至って って簡単です 御所はいりません
誰の許しもいりません
何が起きても心の明るさを保ってみようと試してみることでも
人は成長する いつでも穏やかな気分でいるぞと
何が起きても明るい心でいますよと
やってみてください 心は清らかになります
嫌な気分を作らない 環境が嫌な環境であっても
何とかして明るくしてあげる
信じられないぐらい自分の心が成長します
もう一つあります で これも出家の人々にも教えられている方法で
眼耳鼻舌身意に色声香味触法という情報が触れるんですね
これが知る世界ですね
それから認識が起こるんです
目耳鼻に情報が触れると認識が起こるんです
物事を認識する過程で過程はストップできません
見えること 聞こえることはストップできませんよ
だから心が生まれることもストップ不可能です
心がすーっと生まれるんです
どうにもならない 心は生まれるんです
しかし 物事を知る時です
怒り 欲 嫉妬 落ち込みなどが起こるのは
そこがポイントです 我々は怒ったり
落ち込んだり 欲張ったり
物を惜しんだり 嫉妬したりするのは
あの認識が起こる時なんです
仲間を見た 嫉妬が生まれたと
そのセクションで気をつければいいんです
ものを見たり 聞いたり
味わったりするとき 心に欲と怒りの汚れが起こらないように気をつけることも立派な修行です
普通に生きてみるんです
生きてみるんだけど 心の中に怒りと欲だけは入らないようにと気をつける
美味しいご飯食べますよ
食べるんだけど むちゃくちゃ欲にならないように
これは結構美味しいご飯ですねと
という無執着の気持ちで美味しさは感じる
すごい綺麗な人を見たら
ああ 結構美しいですねとかね
なんていう綺麗な人やとかね
ああいう感情的なところはカットするんです
そこはものすごい立派な修行になるんです
それから瞑想ありますよ
瞑想とは心の訓練なので
しかし脳トレではありません
今 脳トレも流行ってますからね
瞑想実践で認識の欠陥を直せるんです
認識すると 欲 嫉妬 怒りなどなど一切の汚れが生まれるんですね
それは認識の欠陥なんです
プログラムのちょっとしたミスなんですね
瞑想でそこを直すんです
直しちゃえばもう汚れがなくなるんですね
無常の観察 不浄の随念
苦随念 呼吸随念なども実践することができます
いろんな瞑想があります
仏教が推薦している どちらやっても心はの欠陥がね
欲が生まれる 煩悩が生まれる
欠陥が直ります 慈悲の実践もは優れた方法です
その中でも慈悲の実践というのは一番優れているんです
お釈迦様はそれは何よりもヴィパッサナー瞑想と一緒にいつでも紹介するんです
気づきの実践でのヴィパッサナーですね
で 最終的に心が清らかになるんです
あの 16番目の一番最後
アッパマーパマーダ それに対して気づきの瞑想をするんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想するんです
この最後の汚れが落ちると
全部汚れが落ちるんです
だから汚れを落とすために
最終的なプログラムはヴィパッサナー実践ということになります
1日1戦ではなくて 自分の複数の悪から一つ選んで
それから完全解放になるまで努力することも有効です
皆様方 私も人の言葉借りますからね
お釈迦様もやってやってましたから
しょうがないんです あれ
1 日 1 戦という言葉がありますね
日本で あれはやめましょう 1
日1戦だったら あまり戦の数が少ないでしょうに 1
日中悪いことしちゃってね
戦一つだけというのはね
あんまりこの人間にはね
金言は言えませんよ どうしてもどこかで落とし穴があるんです
ではなくて 自分の心の中に複数の悪があるでしょう
複数いたって今日は 16ですからね
これ一つ選ぶんです これを完全に消してみるぞと頑張ればどうですか？と
すべて消えます だから一人一人が私がこれがダメですねとか何か発見する
これ自分で発見するんです
いつでも仏教では主人は自分です
ブッダではないんです
だから自分で じゃあ私の場合はこれがダメですよと
何かダメなものを一つ見つけて
そこは直そう 直そう 直そうと頑張って
完全に直すまで頑張ってみるんです
それだったら このややこしいいろんなことなくても
これだけでもうまくいくんです
これも一つの方法なんです
で 最後の結論で幸福は自分で作るんです
だから私はもう新年のあれとか
あれやこれやとか言わないことにしました
私は別に修復しなくしたってもね
どうったことないでしょうね
やっぱり幸福っていうのは自分で作るものなんです
すべては人の思考次第で起こるものです
すべて思考次第ですね
しかし 人は幸福 幸福を切望するが
思考を選択しようとしないんです
すべて思考次第 思考次第し
幸福は目指すし しかし
思考は汚れているんですね
これ選択しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
そこを忘れているんです
あの すべて自分の心次第とも忘れてますからね
恵みが降ってくると思ってるんです
まあ降ってくるのは災難だけですよ
恵みは降ってこません
恵みは自分で作るんです
ですから 希望とは叶わないもの
その反対が起こるものになっているんです
我々は心が逆さまだから
希望なら叶わない 希望と反対のことが起こる
私は絶対がんにはなりたくないと思っちゃうと
がんになるんです どこかでおかしいんです
がんにはかかりたくないと切望するのは決して悪くないですよ
病気にはなりたくないんだと
しかし それだったら心を清らかにしなさいなんです
答えは 日々の幸福な人生を自分の手で
自分の力で作ってみてはいかがでしょうか
人が救ってくれるまで待たないで
人っていうのはわがままだから忙しいんです
一度も他人が自分に幸福を与えたことはないでしょうに
自分で作るんです はい
それで今日の話は終了です
一応入れました はいはい
一応話は終了です どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
えーと 若干ですが 時間ございますけど
質問などあればで大丈夫です
マイクを回しますが 挙手していただければ
では あの真ん中の方の奥の方
すみません 手を上げるといいですね
マイクの方前に  あの私の娘のことなんですけども
先ほどごまかすとか詐欺というこれはいけないという話でございましたけども
実は今大学一年生なんですが
高校から友達がですね
同じ大学に入ったんですけども
その友達が宿題なんかを全くしないでですね
娘がやったものを見せてくれということで
常にこう自分が楽して人のものを見せてもらう
あるいはこの間試験があって
試験があった時も隣に座ってですね
答えを見せてくれと こういうことで迫られて困っているっていうんですね
で 私はそういう友達は友達じゃないからゲーム切ったらいいんじゃないのというふうに話したんですけども
まあ同じ大学で高校から来たのは一人しかいないし
そんな冷たいことできないよということ一緒に悩んでいるんですけども
娘にどういうふうにアドバイスしたらいいかですね
その辺を教えていただければと思います
よろしくお願いします
まあね そういう性格の人はね
いるんだからね アドバイスしてね
治るならばね もうそれ何よりありがたいことなんですけどね
まあ効かんだろうね じゃあまあ
じゃああなたは自分の人生知ってるでしょうと
あなたはごまかしで詐欺師で生活したいでしょうにと
だからこれから大学をやめてね
どうすれば人を騙すのかと
それ勉強したらどうですか？だってあんた人を騙さないと何もできんでしょうにと
だからまあ仕事をすることになるし
大人にもなるし 社会人にもなるしね
それって騙しでできますかと
騙されたとバレたらあなたどうしますかと
その準備できているのかいと
だからまあ毒と遊ぶなよと
放射汚染物質と遊ぶなよと教えてあげてください
彼女がやっぱりこの放射線を体中塗って温かいと言っているところなんですよ
あの放射物質っていうのは温かいんですよ
温かいのはわかりますけど
あれは触るなよと 触ったらもうずっと
汚染されてますよと 例えば放射線に感染した人がおしっこしたっても
そこを汚染されますからね
それぐらい危険なことやってますよと
だから人は能力なくてもいいんだと
大学に行ったっても 能力ないと思いま・・・ないではなくてね
本人そう思っているんだからね
能力ないと思ってるんだったらそれでいいんだよと
できることをやってよと
いうふうに言うしかないんです
後で苦労するのは見たくないんだと
あのごまかしでね いますよ
弁護士になったり 医者になったり
いろんなことでね もう金使っていろいろでね
後で大変悩む羽目になりますよ
自分で責任持つということになったところで
同じ人々は結構私の周りにもあったけどね
やっぱりまあ それから一生詐欺で通る能力ある人はそれで通っちゃいますけどね
だからといって人間としては情けないんですね
危ない橋を渡ってますね
やっぱり放射線の例えでも教えてあげてください
温かいのはわかりますけど
これはもう自己破壊だと
はい はい こちらの方にまいり
先ほど受付でサンガ出版の心と仏教というのをいただいたんですけども
この中でえーと 精神科医の斉藤環先生がこんなふうに書いていますね
テーラワーダ仏教では精神病は精神科医にという原則があるようなので
このはい テーラワーダ仏教では精神病は精神科医にという原則があるようなので
この点については見分けと信頼関係が成立しているように思うと書かれて
例えばてんかんだとか発達障害だとか
あるいは統合失調症とか
そういうものっていうのは精神科の先生たちがやるというふうに書いていますけども
例えば私はアルコール依存症なんですけども
お酒やめてしばらく経ったんですけども
今日のそのスマナサーラ先生の話したことは
ほとんど私は自分に起きたこととほとんど同じだなと思ってるんですね
でも 例えばアルコール依存症
精神病の範囲だと思うんです
どんな風にそれを分けたらいいのかな
精神病もいろいろあると思いますけども
うん 内容で 仏教ではテーラワーダ仏教ではこんなものは使いませんという明確な線引きってあるんですか？ あります
やっぱり自分で何とかしたいとね
思っている人々はどこかで常識的なところも残ってますから
その人々はもう大丈夫です
まあ自分にはどうにもならないというような
他人が強引に何か薬でもあげないと治らない状態になっちゃうと
もうかなり人間性までもう消えてるでしょ
で その人々はまあ精神科に行った方が
行っても治らないんだけど
もうなんとかもうごまかしはしてくれる
やっぱり仏教は心の病気を治すことだから
治れないっていうことじゃないんです
例えば もう極度に精神的な病気の人でもかかっちゃえば治せますよ
しかし 私たちの仕事はそれじゃなくて
人々に心を清らかにして調子った状態に達することを教えることなんです
だから ああいう人々にはつきっきりで面倒見なくちゃいけないんです
だからもうやらないんです
そこで治しても時間間に合わないんですね
なんとなく まあまあ一応 OK になりましたという普通に戻っただけなんです
普通の戻った人にもまだ長いプログラムありますから
悟りに達するまでね だからそこで効率的なことを考えてね
あの 自分で何とかしたいなという自分のプライド
まだまだ残っている人々には
もうちゃんと指導する
自分のプライドまでなくなったらもう動物と同じですよ
だからしょうがないんですね
悲しいんだけど そういう世界の専門家に任せるしかないんです
あの精神的な問題というのはもう治ります
しかし この病気になったら
なかなかこの本人が言うことをやってくれないんです
常識な人間もそうでしょう
例えば質問前に質問でもね
まあなんか詐欺的なことやってるんだと
これ大変やと思いますよ
言っても言っても聞いてくれないと思いますよ
そこはややこしいんですね
これ病気になると もうなおさら大変です
だから医者も治してあげようという気持ちは全くないんです
ただ まあそういう症状
そういう症状で このお薬
このお薬やっていうことで
まあ見放されるんですよ
見放すんですね だから
これは私たちには人を見放すっていうことはできないんです
だから そこをそこをちゃんと仕事をカンカスは考えるんです
あのもう一つ 医療的にやるべきところは禁止です
仏教には ブッダが禁止しているのです
精神病でもアルコール依存症の人であっても
ちょっと医療のところまで行っちゃうと
体も異常的になってますから
そこら辺はお医者さんがなんとか手当てしなくちゃいけないんですね
それ ちょっと一歩前だったらもう OK です
罪の場合も同じなんで
人は罪を犯したんだからといって
私たちは全然大げさに思いません
たとえ人を殺したことがあっても
もう大丈夫で 気にすんなよと
これから言うことをやってくださいと心を軽らかにする方法を教えます
が 親を殺しちゃったらもうごめんということをしなくちゃいけないんです
いわゆる良いことをしなさいと
しかし 悟りに達するとかね
集中力がつくれるとかはもう期待しない方がいいと
いくら頑張っても無理やと
もう線を越えちゃったと
で  100人人を殺しちゃっても
もうなんとか治せます
親殺しちゃうとできない
病気はちょっと線を越えているんです
人を殺すことが病気です
おっぱい焼けて親を殺しちゃったら
そういうふうにちょっと線はあります
はい  やはり大宗教の中で生きてくると
やはりいろんなものにすがったり祈ったりっていうのが習慣になってますが
やはりそういうことはすべて邪見だと考えていいでしょうか
すべて  邪見なのだと 良くないことなの
じゃああまりにも信じちゃうと
これこそ正しいと思っちゃうと邪見であって
まあ習慣やと思っちゃえば邪見じゃないんですね
ありがとうございます
うん その差な習慣とか文化とかね
だと思っちゃえば大丈夫です
はい 他の質問があったらな
手伝いのところで質問したいんですが
人に気に入られようとかっていうようなこととかっていうのも
ちょっと私 耳がちょっと遠いんです
すいません 人に気に入られてよとかですね
というのは 手伝い 欲というか
へつらいというようなところになるんでしょうか
人に見られたい 見られる
よく見られたいとか  よく見られないってこと
人に気に入られたいというようなことが
そこを気になっちゃうと
やっぱりへつらいところになりがちですよ
だから人が管理できんでしょうに
そんなの放っておくんです
あなたどう思ったっても関係ないやと
私はしっかりやってるんだよ
いう態度を取らなくちゃいけないんです
だから私のこともいろいろ言われますよ
全然気にしないんです
だからできるだけ知らないことにするんです
知ったら私はまたすごいこと言っちゃいますから
だから私が例えばすごい無責任でいい加減に批判するでしょ
宗教とかね 本当は徹底的に調べているんです
世界の一流の学者たちの意見をよく見て
あの聖書を批判するのは
アメリカでも一流のプリンストンにあるトップグレードの大学のもう一生聖書を教えた先生の本からなんです
だからもう全然怖くないんで
何言われたっても だからそういう
そういうふうにしてください
はい  家系のことなんですが
今 私のパートの収入で食費を賄ってるんですね
主人は年金生活なんです
...あの仕事がなくなっちゃって
無収入に近い で 私の家計で食費を賄っていることが
あの主人に対して怒りが発生してるんですね
それで今までずっと養ってきてもらって
ちゃんとしてもらってきた主人なんですけど
働けなくなったら腹が立ってきちゃって
それでどう私はあれでしょうか
やっぱりダメでしょうか
うん まああれ気にしない方がいいんだけど
俺 女性の宿命だからね
結局は腹が立つこともね
まあそれは女性だからそう腹が立ってしまってしょうがないと気づけば
それでまあ大丈夫なんです
どうしても女性っていうのは人を管理したくなるんですね
だからあの退職して今年金もらってるご主人を自分で管理したいんですね
だから働けこの野郎と思っちゃうんです
だから管理したくなっても
だから向こうは動く動くかどうかわからないでしょ
だから子供にも勉強しろ
勉強しろって言うんだけど
もう腹が立ってしょうがないんだけど
でも勉強するかしないかっていうと
まあ本人がね また別な問題だから
それ勉強してほしいんですね
まあどうせ私も偶然なんとかね
もうプライド捨てて なんとかもうちょっとした収入でもね
いるようなことをやった方が本人にとってもいいと思いますけど
それはそんな感じで言ってみたらどうですかね
あんた早くもう寝たきりになっちゃったらね
あなた苦しいでしょうにと
ですから なんとかした方がいいんだよと
あの この養うということが
まあ普通は男の仕事なんですが
やっぱり世界は女のものでしょうに
存在の中でオスには何の立場もないんです
だから 例えば旦那が早く死んじゃったとする
子供が二人がいるとする
お母さんやりますよ 全部
なんとか仕事もして 収入を持ってきて
子供の面倒を見る 育てることもする
そこまで男にはできないんです
だから まあそういうふうにも女性で生まれたら
まあそういうまあ男にはできない大量の仕事っていうのは
まあもうついてきます
もうどうにもならん これが
で その分力もありますからね
そんなにあんまりも自分をいじめない方がいいんです
だから管理しているんだということを覚えておいてください
管理してください 旦那を
そうするともうなんとかなると思います
怒っただけで管理してないでしょ
おそらく そこは管理してください
男っていうのは命令に動くんです
笑い はいはい どうぞどうぞ
あ すいません 疑いって言って
今の政治の世界でもお互い与野党やってやり合っておりますけども
私の個人の生活でもそうなる場合があるんですけども
疑いに対する 対策というか
どうそれに対応したらいいかということをお聞きしたい
うんうん 私も政治家のことっていうのは結構調べたりはしますけど
私には関係ないんだけど
やっぱりどうしても調べちゃうんですね
だから私の判断で言えばね
あんまり当てにならないんですね
特に日本の政治っていうのはずっと当てにならなかったしね
やっぱり国民一人一人は自分の幸福を自分で考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
で まあいい気持ちで頑張ろうと思っている人々もいないわけじゃない
いますけど 周りはやらせないんですね
だからまあ 自分の利益を先にする
自分の権力を先に考えるということは
政治家の普通常識になっているんですね
だから 自分の権力と自分の立場をもう優先にしちゃうと
もう当てにならないんですね
だから まあ付き合っているならば
ほどほど適当にというところにして
やっぱりここ日本は今までもよくうまくいったのは国民が頑張ったんだからなんです
政治政治システムが良かったんだからではないんです
で 私の分析では よくもこの子が日本に来て 30年ぐらい前ね
ですから よくもよく調べたんですよ
調べたら よくもこの国がうまくいってるんだと信じられないとまず思ったんですよ
これほど悪システムができて
人の幸福を壊す 中小企業が壊れる
倒産するシステムが作って
個人には採算が入らない
なんか共産主義みたいですね
明確な共産主義的な資本主義で抑えられて
個人をむちゃくちゃ馬鹿にしちゃって
よくもやるんでしょうと
しかし 国を見たらうまくいってるんだと
やっぱり一人一人が頑張っているんです
いくら叩かれても 国民はひたすら頑張るんです
いい人間ですよ もうちょっとマシな政治家があればね
天国みたいになるはずなんですけどね
マシな政治家がいたら
日本が次の世界第１国になれることもそんなに夢じゃないんです
中国はね あんまりにも人口がありすぎちゃって
資源があって さっさと目覚めただけで
もう日本は全部揃っていたんだからね
ただ管理するべきところだけダメでしたしね
初めからそうなんです
今更ではないんです だからこれは直らないし
まあこれからも自分のことは自分で頑張りますと思うしかないんじゃないかなと思います
こんな赤字国家を作ったのは国民じゃないでしょうね
国民はもうちょっとしっかりした方がいいね
国民もあんまりね なんかすごいおかしいんですよ
これが誰かリーダーがないんですね
もっと真面目に物事を考えなさいとかね
言いたいところは国民にも文句言いたいところありますけど
それは私が  何て言うんですかね
そこは言える人間もいないし
まあとにかくあの まあ政治というのはそんなに一般人のことを心配する仕事じゃないんですね
あれは洗脳ですね 世界の政治家が我々を洗脳しているんです
国民のために頑張っているんだと
そうやってない 現実的には
アメリカ政府もね 偉そうなこと言うでしょ
アメリカは国民のために
自由のためにとか とんでもない嘘で
ただ単に戦争を売っているだけで
あちこち あのテロリストの国々とはもうどんなに性格的に差がないんです
そこでまあ どこかでアメリカ人が逮捕したところで
法律を犯したんだからしょうがないんだけど
それで強行に行くんですね
なぜかというと その国を責められます
では アメリカにいる国民を守ってくるのかというと
全然守ってあげてないんです
それで自分のこと自分で守りなさいと平気で言うんです
例えばみんな鉄砲を持つべきやとかね
すごい考えがあるんですよ
一人 まあアメリカ人が一人一人が自分を守ることは
まあ武器を持ってでも自分を守るべきであると
だから武器を持つ権利が必要であると
ということは 政府は何もやらなくてもよろしいということなんです
はい まあそんなところですね
やっぱりこれはもう昔も同じことですから
まあ今更直るということもないし
あの それほど期待しないということも一番いいんです
我々の日常の収入に邪魔するならば
商売に邪魔するならば
そこは凶暴で訴えた方がいいんですね
やっぱりこの国際競争で日本が負けているのは
会社が頑張ってますよ
会社一人で外国に行ってね
政府相手に頑張るということは無理です
日本の政府は政府として支えてないんです
各会社が自分が訴えられちゃって
まあ世界を訴えてね アメリカだけですけど
もうトヨタ会社に訴える
あの会社 この会社とかね
ちょっと儲かったら全部 3倍にして戻してもらう
だからまあそちらはそう頑張って
こちらは日本の政府は何もしないんですね
うーん だから大変だと思いますよ
じゃあ私の答えはもう耐えられないことですね
いい人々がいますよ いろんなビジョンを持ってる人々はね
でも 何もできん やらせません
そういうことで仏教はほとんどまあ
政治にはもう関わらないというふうな態度をとっています
はい  はい それではお時間になりましたので
ここで終了させていただきたいと思います
それでは回向の文で終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますよう
そして目覚められますよう
サッビーティヨイワンジャントゥーサンバローゴーイナッサトゥマーテーバワットワンタラーヨースケーリーガーユコーバワーバワトゥサンバマンガランラッカント
ゥサンバデヴァタサンバブッダヌーバヴェーナサンバダンマヌーバヴェーナ
サッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティ バヴァンチュ テ
アビワダナシーリッソ ニッチャン ワッダーパチャイノ
チャッターロ ダンマ ワッダンティ アユワンノ スカン バラン
はい では終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます